less than 24 hours ago Google released
the Palm 2 technical report I have read
all 92 Pages watch the Palm 2
presentation read the release notes and
have already tested the model in a dozen
ways but before getting into it all my
four main takeaways are these first Palm
2 is competitive with gpt4 and while it
is probably less smart overall it's
better in certain ways and that
surprised me second Google is saying
very little about the data it used to
train the model or about parameters or
about compute although we can make
educated guesses on each third Gemini
was announced to be in training and will
likely rival GPT 5 while arriving
earlier than GPT 5. as you probably know
Sam Altman said that gbt5 isn't in
training and won't be for a long time
fourth while dedicating 20 pages to bias
toxicity and misgendering there wasn't a
single page on AI impacts more broadly
Google boasted of giving Gemini planning
abilities in a move that surprises I am
to say it makes open AI look like
Paragons of responsibility so a lot to
get to but let's look at the first
reason that Palm 2 is different from a
gpt4 on page 3 they say we designed a
more multilingual and diverse
pre-training mixture extending across
hundreds of languages and domains like
programming mathematics Etc so because
of the text that they train Palm 2 on is
different to the text that openai train
gpd4 on it means that those models have
different abilities and I would say Palm
2 is better at translation and
Linguistics and in certain other areas
which I'll get to shortly if that's data
what about parameter count well Google
never actually say they only use words
like it's significantly smaller than the
largest Palm model which was 540 billion
parameters so sometimes they say
significantly other times dramatically
despite this it's significantly
outperforms Palm on a variety of tasks
so all the references you may have seen
to imminent 100 trillion parameter
models were bogus skipping ahead to page
91 out of 92 in the model summary they
say further details of model size and
architecture are withheld from external
publication but earlier on they did seem
to want to give hints about the
parameter count inside Palm 2 which
openai never did here they present the
optimal number of parameters given a
certain amount of compute flops scaling
this up to the estimated number of flops
used to train Palm 2. that would give an
optimal parameter count of between 100
and 200 billion that is a comparable
parameter count to gpt3 while getting
competitive performance with gpt4 Bard
is apparently now powered by Palm 2 and
the inference speed is about 10 times
faster than gbt4 for the exact same
prompt and I know there are other
factors that influence inference speed
but that would broaden fit with an order
of magnitude fewer parameters this has
other implications of course and they
say that Palm 2 is dramatically smaller
cheaper and faster to serve not only
that part 2 itself comes in different
sizes as Sundar pichai said Palm 2
models deliver excellent foundational
capabilities across a wide range of
sizes
we've affectionately named them gecko
order bison and unicorn
gecko is so lightweight that it can work
on mobile devices
fast enough for great interactive
applications on device even when offline
I would expect gecko to soon be inside
the Google pixel phones going back to
data Google cryptically said that the
pre-training Corpus is composed of a
diverse set of sources documents books
code mathematics and conversational data
I've done a whole video on the data
issues that these companies face but
suffice to say they're not saying
anything about where the data comes from
next they don't go into detail but they
do say that Palm 2 was trained to
increase the context length of a model
significantly beyond that of palm as of
today you can input around 10 000
characters into Bard but they end this
paragraph with something a bit more
interesting they say without
demonstrating our results show that it
is possible to increase the context
length of the model without hurting its
performance on generic benchmarks the
bit about not hurting performance is
interesting because in this experiment
published a few weeks ago about
extending the input size in token up to
around 2 million tokens the performance
did drop off if Google have found a way
to increase the input size in tokens and
not affect performance that would be a
breakthrough on multilingual benchmarks
notice how the performance of palm 2 in
English is not dramatically better than
in other languages in fact in many other
languages it does better than in English
this is very different to gpd4 which was
noticeably better in English than in all
other languages as Google hinted earlier
this is likely due to the multilingual
Text data that Google trained Palm 2
with in fact on page 17 Google admit
that the performance of palm 2 exceeds
Google Translate for certain languages
and they show on page 4 that it can pass
the Mastery exams across a range of
languages like Chinese Japanese Italian
French Spanish German Etc look at the
difference between Palm 2 and palm in
red now before you rush off and try Bard
in all of those languages I tried that
and apparently you can only use Bard at
the moment in the following languages
English US English what a Pity and
Japanese and Korean but I was able to
test Bard in Korean on a question
translated via Google Translate from the
mmlu dataset it got the question right
in each of its drafts in contrast Gypsy
4 not only got the question wrong in
Korean when I originally tested it for
my smart GPT video it got the question
wrong in English in case any of my
regular viewers are wondering I am
working very hard on Smart GPT to
understand what it's capable of and
getting it benchmarked officially and
thank you so much for all the kind
offers of help in that regard I must
admit it was very interesting to see on
page 14 a direct comparison between Palm
2 and gpt4 and Google do admit for the
Palm 2 results they use Chain of Thought
prompting and self-consistency reading
the self-consistency paper did remind me
quite a lot actually of smart GPT where
it picks the most consistent answer of
multiple outputs so I do wonder if this
comparison is totally fair if Palm 2
used this method and gpt4 didn't I have
to talk about these benchmarks more in
another video otherwise this one would
be too long a quick hint is that why no
Grand is about identifying what the
pronoun in a sentence refers to Google
also weighed into the emerging abilities
debate saying that Palm 2 does indeed
demonstrate new emerging abilities they
say it does so in things like multi-step
arithmetic problems temporal sequences
and hierarchical reasoning of course I'm
going to test all of those and have
begun to do so already and in my early
experiments I'm getting quite an
interesting result Palm 2 gets a lot of
questions wrong that gpt4 gets right but
it can also get questions right that
gpt4 gets wrong and I must admit it's
really weird to see Palm 2 getting
really Advanced college level math
questions right that gpd4 gets wrong and
yet also when I ask it a basic question
about prime numbers it gets it kind of
hilariously wrong honestly I'm not
certain what's going on there but I do
have my suspicions remember though that
recent papers have claimed that emergent
abilities are a mirage so Google begs to
differ when Google put Palm 2 up against
GT4 in high school mathematics problems
it did outperform gpd4 but again it was
using an advanced prompting strategy not
a hundred percent different from Smart
GPT so I wonder if the comparison is
quite Fair what about coding well again
it's really hard to find a direct
comparison that's fair between the two
models overall I would guess that the
specialized coding model of palm what
they call Palm 2s is worse than Gypsy 4.
it says it's pass at one accuracy as in
past first time is 37.6 remember the
Sparks of AGI paper well that gave GT4
as having an 82 percent zero shot pass
at one accuracy level however as I
talked about in the Sparks of AGI video
the paper admits that it could be that
Gypsy 4 has seen and memorized some or
all of human eval there is one thing I
will give Google credit on which is that
their code now sometimes references
where it came from here is a brief
extract from the Google keynote
presentation how would I use Python to
generate the scholars move in chess okay
here Bard created a script to recreate
this chess move in Python and notice how
it also formatted the code nicely making
it easy to read we've also heard great
feedback from developers about how Bard
provides code citations and starting
next week you'll notice something right
here we're making code citations even
more precise if Bard brings in a block
of code just click this annotation and
Bard will underline the block and link
to the source as always it seems the
appendix contained more interesting
information sometimes than the main body
of the technical report for example we
get a direct and fair comparison between
Gypsy 4 and palm 2 or I should say flan
Palm 2. that is the instruction
fine-tuned version of palm 2.
essentially that's the version where
it's been fine-tuned to get better at
following a question and answer format
but anyway the original palm 2 scored
78.3 and flan Palm 2 scored 81.2 that's
below the 86.4 percent of GT4 and that's
why my broad conclusion is that Gypsy 4
is a bit smarter than Palm 2 but as I'll
be showing over the coming days and
weeks there are genuinely quite a few
areas in which palm 2 is better than
gpt4 what about the big bench which was
designed to be particularly tough for
language models I talked a lot about
this in my earliest videos well the
graph is going to look pretty weird
because Palm 2 has improved upon Palm
while reducing the number of parameters
so the graph kind of doubles back on
itself back up here up to around 69
according to the technical report I
would say this is quite a major moment
in human history there is now virtually
no language task that the average human
can do better than palm 2. of course
expert humans can do better in
individual domains but the average human
is now worse in virtually every domain
of language here you can see that
confirmation of the big bench hard
results for flan Palm 2 69.1
interestingly in the original chart Palm
2 is even claimed to have higher
performance than that at 78.1 if you
remember the reason we can't compare
that to gpd4 is that in the technical
report for gpt4 they admit that during
their contamination check we discovered
that portions of big bench were
inadvertently mixed into the training
set and we excluded it from our reported
results before we get to Gemini Google
show off in the latter half of the
technical report with examples of of
linguistic ability like writing
paragraphs in tajiki and then
translating them into Persian they go on
to show examples in Tamil and they are
really making a big point of showing off
its multilingual capabilities at this
point and I'm going to admit this is my
personal opinion Google then Strays into
dozens of pages on bias toxicity and
gender interestingly some of the people
paid to assess these risks were paid
only 1.5 cents per judgment these things
do need to be addressed of course but it
was somewhat shocking to me to see 20
pages of that and not a single page on
the broader AI impacts as many of you
may know I have criticized openai plenty
of times on this channel but compare
their technical report which goes into
far more detail about what we need to
monitor the closest Google got was
showing how their Universal translator
could be used for deep fakes Universal
translators and experimental AI video
dubbing service that helps experts trans
later speak his voice while also
matching their lip movements let me show
you how it works with an online college
course created in partnership with
Arizona State University what many
college students don't realize is that
knowing when to ask for help and then
following through and using helpful
resources is actually a Hallmark of
becoming a productive adult
universities
it just seems a massive black hole when
one of their recent former employees
Jeffrey Hinton had this to say this week
on CNN you've spoken out saying that AI
could manipulate or possibly figure out
a way to kill humans how could it kill
humans if it gets to be much smarter
than us it'll be very good at
manipulation because it will have
learned that from us and very few
examples of a more intelligent thing
being controlled by a less intelligent
thing and it knows how to program so
it'll figure out ways of getting round
restrictions as we put on it it'll
figure out ways of manipulating people
to do what it wants it's not clear to me
that we can solve this problem
um I believe we should put a big effort
into thinking about ways to solve the
problem I don't have a solution at
present I just want people to be aware
that this is a really serious problem
and we need to be thinking about it very
hard this all seems particularly
relevant when Google made this
announcement about Gemini their rival to
Gypsy 5. all this helps set the stage
for the inflection point we are at today
we recently brought these two teams
together into a single unit Google
deepmind using the computational
resources of Google they are focused on
building more capable systems safely and
responsibly
this includes our next Generation
Foundation model Gemini which is still
in training
Gemini was created from the ground up to
be multimodal
highly efficient at tool and API
Integrations and built to enable future
Innovations like memory and planning
that ability to plan may ring a bell
from the gpt4 technical report which
said this novel capabilities often
emerge in more powerful models some that
are particularly concerning are the
ability to create and act on long-term
plans remember Google didn't identify
planning as a risk but as a selling
point for Gemini next Google talked
about accelerating their progress which
was again directly mentioned in the gpt4
technical report it said one concern of
particular importance to open AI is the
risk of racing Dynamics leading to a
decline in safety standards the
diffusion of bad norms and accelerated
AI timelines Each of which heightens
societal risks associated with AI we
refer to these here as acceleration risk
and make no mistake Gemini will be very
accelerated from Palm 2. it looks set to
use the the TPU V5 chip which was
announced back in January of last year
and on page 91 of the Palm 2 technical
report they say that that model used TPU
V4 now it should be said that Palm 2 is
leading to some impressive medical
applications as I actually first
reported on seven weeks ago without
quite realizing it here's Med Palm 2. We
Believe large language models have the
potential to revolutionize Healthcare
and benefit Society mad Palm is a large
language model that we've taken and
tuned for the medical domain
you know medical question answering has
been a research Grand Challenge for
several decades but till date the
progress has been kind of slow but then
over the course of the last three to
four months first with metform and
metform2 we have kind of like broken
through that barrier unlike previous
versions mad Palm 2 was able to score 85
on the usmla medical licensing exam yeah
this is immensely exciting because
people have been working on medical
question answering for over three
decades and finally we are at a stage
where we can say with confidence that AI
systems can now at least answer USMLE
questions as good as experts as many of
you may know the CEO of Google as well
as the CEO of Microsoft and Sam Altman
and the CEO of anthropic all went to the
White House to discuss AI risk and
opportunity but given that the main
outcome from that seems to be 140
million to establish seven new AI
research institutes that feels a little
slow given all the acceleration that's
occurring because as Google somewhat
soberly conclude their rapport we
believe that further scaling of both
model parameters and data set size and
quality as well as improvements in the
architecture and objective we'll
continue to yield gains in language
understanding and generation they are
not slowing down and the world hasn't
yet caught up thank you so much for
watching to the end and have a wonderful
day